This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个iHeart播客。真人保证。嘿，大家好，你们好吗？欢迎收听《艰难抉择》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个节目聚焦于黑人男性的生活经历，进行坦诚的对话，而这些对话在其他任何地方其实都不安全，但你是在跟一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人带着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，听听如何学习。
the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Mancini.
用AHA电台应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难抉择》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·曼奇尼。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我的天呐。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《受困之爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《受困之爱》播客。2%。这是当旁边有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、体能训练的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。也就是TWA percent，在iHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说
that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show, welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world right now. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Before we begin, I'm just going to say I'm a little bit under the weather. I unfortunately have COVID.
相信你的闺蜜。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《闺蜜：相信我，宝贝》。欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十岁时的一些重大生活变化和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好，欢迎回到本节目，欢迎回到本播客，新听友，老听友，无论你现在身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听新的一集。在开始之前，我只想说我有点身体不舒服。我不幸感染了新冠。
I know. So sad. So if my voice is a little bit croaky and gross, please do not DM me saying that I see. sound weird. That is why it gets us all at some stage. So that's where we are at the moment. But it's not going to stop us from talking about today's topic because today we're going to talk about how we can stop overthinking and worrying about the future. I think it is such a common experience in our 20s to be filled with a lot of doubt, a lot of insecurity, a lot of uncertainty about what's going to happen.
我知道。太难过了。所以如果我的声音听起来有点沙哑难听，请不要私信我说我听起来很奇怪。这就是原因，我们在某个阶段都会中招。这就是我们目前的情况。但这不会阻止我们讨论今天的话题，因为今天要探讨的是我们如何停止过度思考和对未来的担忧。我认为在二十几岁的时候，充满了许多怀疑、许多不安、许多对未来会发生什么的不确定性，这是非常普遍的体验。
You know, the world is so large. We have so many choices and there are so many unknowns that we can almost feel paralyzed with anxiety. And I have been there. I'm sure you have too. Maybe you're worried about your career choices, whether you'll find a love, whether you'll be happy in 10 years,
你知道，世界如此之大。我们有那么多的选择，有那么多的未知数，以至于我们几乎会因为焦虑而感到瘫痪。我曾经经历过。我确信你也是。也许你正在为你的职业选择、是否能找到真爱、十年后是否会幸福而担忧，
making enough money, or even bigger existential questions around climate change. and the economy. It can be really, really crippling. But I also really do believe that understanding our reaction and our fear of the future from a psychological perspective can be really liberating. So we're going to break down some really incredible concepts today that relate to overthinking the future from our natural stress response to the paradox of choice, the illusion of control, self-preservation, so much more, so that we can find freedom from anticipatory anxiety about the future. The way I see it is that when you worry about something, you take away from the now.
赚够钱，甚至围绕气候变化和经济等更大的存在主义问题。这真的会让人感到非常非常崩溃。但我也真的相信，从心理学的角度来理解我们对未来的反应和恐惧，其实是非常具有解放意义的。所以今天我们要剖析一些非常不可思议的概念，它们都与过度思考未来有关，从我们自然的压力反应到选择悖论、控制幻觉、自我保护等等，这样我们就能摆脱对未来的预期的焦虑。在我看来，当你为某事担忧时，你就从当下抽离了。
And a really beautiful quote I heard the other day said that when you worry about something, you experience it twice. obviously we can understand that and know that our fears about the future are irrational but applying this wisdom is a lot more difficult trust me i repeat those words to myself so many times and i still find myself awake late into the afternoons late into the evenings paralyzed about what my future has in store so alongside a discussion of the origins of future spiraling as i call it, we're also going to walk through some of the psychological tips from Buddhism to dancing and mind-body work, to stay present and to stop worrying so much about what the future has in store for us. It's a big one. It's a deep and existential episode for sure. So without further ado,
我前几天听到一句非常美丽的名言，上面说，当你为某事担忧时，你其实经历了它两次。显然我们可以理解并知道我们对未来的恐惧是不理性的，但应用这个智慧要困难得多，相信我，我对自己重复了那么多遍这些话，却依然发现自己在深夜里、在傍晚时分醒来，为我的未来会发生什么而感到动弹不得。因此，除了讨论我所谓的“未来螺旋式焦虑”的起源之外，我们还将探讨一些心理学技巧，从佛教到舞蹈和身心工作，以保持当下，停止为未来可能发生的事情过度担忧。这是一个很大的话题。这绝对是一个深刻且具有存在主义意义的一集。所以废话不多说，
let's jump into it. This episode is dedicated to the people like myself who find themselves spiraling and overthinking the future. It's dedicated to the people who are already worrying for themselves in five years, who are constantly questioning their decisions, double-guessing themselves, and stressed about life's many unknowns. I've been there. I am still there. So let's break it down together and dive into exactly how we can stop overthinking and worrying about our futures. I think it needs to be said anxiety about the future is an entirely natural response. As much as it is frustrating and overwhelming, like I said before, life is full of a lot of unknowns and novel experiences and situations that we need to find ways to navigate, especially in our 20s. Much of what we're
让我们直接切入主题。这一集献给那些像我一样发现自己在未来中陷入螺旋和过度思考的人。它献给那些已经在为五年后的自己担忧，不断质疑自己的决定、自我怀疑并为生活中的许多未知数感到压力的人。我曾经经历过。我现在也依然如此。所以让我们一起剖析它，深入探讨我们到底该如何停止过度思考并担忧我们的未来。我认为必须要说的是，对未来的焦虑是一种完全自然的反应。尽管它令人沮丧和不知所措，就像我之前说的，生活充满了许多未知数和新奇的体验以及我们需要找到方法去应对的情境，尤其是在我们的二十几岁。我们所经历的很大一部分，
going through, we are experiencing for the first time as adults. And there is no guidebook. There is no amount of advice that is ever going to make us feel assured and that we're making the right decisions. And that is really, really scary. I think our generation has also been forced to carry the burden of some really intense existential problems, you know, worrying about the state of the climate, the state of our environment, about nuclear weapons, how the bees are doing the economy, and even a potential recession. It's a lot to take. It's a lot to take. on. It's a lot to carry, especially when we feel so hopeless and unable to change some of those situations. You know, I'm always so surprised when I come across news articles being like, why are
都是我们作为成年人的第一次体验。而且没有任何指南。没有任何建议能让我们感到安心，觉得我们正在做出正确的决定。这真的是非常非常可怕的。我认为我们这一代人还被迫承担了一些非常强烈的存在主义问题的负担，你知道，担忧气候状况、环境状况、核武器、蜜蜂的生存状况、经济，甚至是潜在的经济衰退。这需要承受太多了。这需要承受太多了。这需要承担太多，尤其是当我们感到如此绝望、无力改变其中某些情况的时候。你知道，每当我看到一些新闻文章在问，为什么千禧一代或二十几岁的年轻人会这么焦虑？为什么他们背离传统工作？为什么他们对现状不满意？我就感到非常惊讶，而事实是，当你不确定自己是否甚至还有一个未来时，我们怎么能不感到焦虑呢？我认为这是一种极其普遍的体验，将我们这十年的许多人紧密联系在一起。事情就是这样。对未来感到几乎瘫痪或不知所措，其实是很正常的。但我真正想做的是，解释一些导致这种现象发生的科学和心理学原因，特别是它如何与压力和焦虑等概念相关联，它如何与自我保护和社会比较相关联。以及社会比较。首先，让我们剖析一下，为什么我们当中的一些人，在面对那个宏大的问题时，会产生一种本质上被拉长的、慢性的焦虑感？未来会怎样？我要做什么？压力是对不确定性的一种自然反应。当我们暴露在一个未知的情境中时，比如对未来的展望，我们的大脑会本能地感到恐惧。因为这些情境、这些未知的情境可能包含危险，它希望我们做好准备。所以它会释放去甲肾上腺素和皮质醇等荷尔蒙，在完全无意识的情况下让我们的身体做好准备，以应对它所感知到的威胁，即使这个威胁还要多年之后才会到来。这种感觉还有另一个名字。它叫做预期的焦虑。
millennials or 20-year-old so anxious? Why are they turning away from traditional jobs? Why are they not happy with the way things are? And it's like, well, when you're not sure you'll even have a future, how are we expected to not feel anxious? I think that's an incredibly common experience that unites a lot of us in this decade. And here's the thing. It's really normal to feel almost paralysed or overwhelmed by the future. But what I really want to do is explain some of the scientific and psychological reasons why that occurs, particularly how it relates to concepts like stress and anxiety, how it relates to self-preservation and social comparison. And social comparison. Firstly, let's break down exactly why some of us have what is essentially an elongated
这就是你在事件发生之前所体验到的恐惧或担忧。所以如果你发现自己在为那些可能会发生的糟糕、未知的事情感到苦恼，这就是你正在体验预期焦虑的指标。这种情况的发生是因为我们的思想集中在可能的未来或我们感觉没有准备好的消极结果上。所以如果你注意到自己高度集中于可怕的、不想要的结果，如果你发现自己变得非常绝望或沮丧，因为你不知道自己在做什么，
and chronic sense of anxiety when it comes to that big question. What does the future hold? What am I going to do? Stress is a natural response to uncertainty. When we are exposed to an unknown situation, such as the prospect of our future, our brain is naturally fearful. because these situations, these unknown situations, could contain danger and it wants us to be prepared. So it releases hormones like noropenephrine and cortisol to prepare our bodies entirely unconsciously to deal with what it perceives as a threat, even if that threat is years away. This feeling has another name. It's called anticipatory anxiety.
如果你总是预料到一个糟糕的结果，或者对你的未来产生不理性的想法，比如，你知道，如果我现在不做正确的决定，我到30岁就会很惨，或者我会一无所有，或者我永远也找不到真爱，感受到那种不理性的、极其强烈的恐惧感并感到高度忧虑，这表明你可能对自己的未来产生了预期焦虑。你可能已经猜到了，多项研究表明，这与其他病症（如广泛性焦虑症和抑郁症）有关。那是因为过度思考和这种性质的反应被视为这两种病症的副产品。
and this is the fear or dread you experience before an event even occurs. So if you find yourself agonising about the horrible, unknown things that might happen, this is an indicator that you're experiencing anticipatory anxiety. And it happens because our thoughts are focused on a possible future or a negative outcome that we don't feel prepared for. So if you notice yourself intensely focused on fearful, unwanted outcomes, if you find yourself becoming really hopeless or frustrated, that you don't know what you're doing,
同样的神经元被激活，身体体验到同样的事情，只是在响应不同的触发因素，而在这种情况下，是一个高度抽象的触发因素。它是对作为我们未来的那个触发因素的反应。因此，那些已经被诊断出患有这些疾病的人，往往报告出比普通人群更高的预期焦虑发生率，这也毫不奇怪。所以这就是为什么我们中的一些人会对未来产生这种不理性的、全方位的恐惧和担忧的原因之一。那么，为什么我们的大脑会这样做呢？为什么我们会发现自己在陷入螺旋式担忧，通常甚至在我们不想要的时候？当我们明知它是不逻辑的，而且无论如何也对情况毫无帮助时。我们无法预测未来，但我们的焦虑喜欢说服我们我们可以。
if you're always expecting a bad outcome, or having irrational thoughts about your future, like, you know, if I don't make the right decision now, I'm going to be miserable by 30, or I'll be destitute, or I'll have nothing, or I'm never going to find love, feeling that irrational sense of really intense fear and feeling highly apprehensive is a sign that you might have anticipatory anxiety towards your future. You may have guessed this already, but this has been linked across multiple studies to other conditions such as generalized anxiety disorders and depression. that's because overthinking and a reaction of this nature is seen as a byproduct of both of these
这与一个叫做控制幻觉的概念有关。作为一个物种，我们其实不太擅长应对未知，主要是因为它让我们感到无助，从而感到危险。这与自我保护有很大关系，自我保护本质上是我们对生存的先天本能。无论如何，我们都希望确保自己的生存。我们希望得到保护，免受潜在危险或不确定性的伤害。所以担忧像未来这样的事情，反复琢磨它，试图做好准备，这对我们来说有一种奇怪的满足感，因为它让我们觉得我们在某种程度上能够掌控
conditions the same neurons fire the body experiences the same thing it's just in response to a different trigger and in this case a highly abstract one it's in response to the trigger that is our future it's also no surprise that people who have already received a diagnosis for these conditions tend to report higher rates of anticipatory anxiety compared to the general population. So that is one reason why some of us have this irrational, all-consuming fear and worry about the future. So why do our brains do this? Why do we find ourselves spiraling and worrying, often when we don't even want to? When we know it's illogical and it won't help this situation anyway. We can't predict the future, but our anxiety likes to convince us that we can.
并且能够为即将发生的事情做好准备。所以当我们反刍时，它会缓解我们的焦虑，因为它提供了一种感觉，即我们能够预测将发生的事情，并且无论结果如何都知道该怎么做。这就解释了为什么，我不知道你是否曾有过那种强烈的感觉，觉得：“天哪，我太迷茫了，我不知道我想做什么。”然后你坐下来，几乎是把所有精确的步骤都写在日记里或写下来，以指引你到达你想去的地方。你知道，你制定了一个五年计划。在那之后，你感觉好多了。你把它写在了纸上。你对此进行了反复思索。
And this relates to the idea called the illusion of control. So as a species, we're not incredibly great with dealing with the unknown, primarily because it makes us feel helpless and therefore in danger. And this has a lot to do with self-preservation, which is essentially our innate instinct towards survival. we want to ensure our survival no matter what. We want to be protected against potential danger or uncertainty. So worrying about something like the future, mulling it over, trying to prepare, that feels strangely satisfying to us because it allows us to feel like we are in some way in control
你给自己指明了一些前进的方向。你可能会感觉好很多，因为它带给你一种掌控感，让你觉得你已经能够预见未来会发生什么，哪怕只是一秒钟，从而让你内心平静。嗯，我们知道这不是真的。我们没有那种控制力。因此它被称为控制幻觉，因为无论我们多么努力地在脑海中一遍又一遍地权衡一种情况，无论我们多么努力地计划，坐着担忧和沉思，
and can be prepared for what is coming. So when we ruminate, it eases our anxiety because it provides this sense that we are able to anticipate what will happen and know what to do regardless of the outcome. So this explains why, I don't know if you've ever had this really intense sense of like, oh my goodness, I'm super lost, I don't know what I want to do. And you've sat down and you've almost journaled or written out all the exact steps to get you where you want to go. You know, you've made a five-year plan. And afterwards, you feel a lot better. You've put it on the page. You've ruminated over it.
我们未来的很大一部分其实是由命运、运气、我们永远无法预料的环境所决定的。但这并不是一件坏事，你知道，正如我们在这个节目中经常说的那样，最好的结果往往发生在你让生活给你带来惊喜的时候。一次又一次，生活给我的最伟大的礼物，不是在我最期待的时候，而是在我完全意想不到的时候。我们稍后会谈到这一点，特别是我们如何能够适应不确定性。但这也是其中的一部分，对吧？
You've given yourself some idea of a way forward. You probably feel a lot better because it brings you a sense of control and you feel that you've been able to anticipate what the future holds, even for a second, so you're at peace. Well, we know this isn't true. We don't have that control. hence why it's called an illusion of control because as much as we try to turn a situation over and over in our brain, as much as we try to plan and we sit worrying and contemplating,
这种控制幻觉，我们之所以担忧，是因为它让我们觉得自己知道自己在做什么。在我们二十多岁的时候，还有另一个独特的方面，我认为它也真正促成了这种体验，即对未来的自然担忧、选择、机会、敞开的大门。我们的二十多岁在宣传中总是被描绘成一个世界尽在掌握的十年。它就在我们的指尖。我们可以做任何我们想做的事。这是生活真正开始的时候。这最初听起来太棒了。你知道，有什么比选择更好呢？有什么比作为独立、好奇的人去决定我们自己的人生道路拥有无尽的自由更好呢？但在这个例子中，选择实际上可能是一把双刃剑。我想解释一下原因。早在20世纪70年代，一些心理学家希望
so much of our future is decided by, you know, well, by fate, by luck, by circumstances, we can never anticipate. And that is not a bad thing, you know, as we always say on this show, the best outcomes always occur when you let life surprise you. Time and time again, life has given me its greatest gifts, not when I least expected them, but when I didn't expect them at all. And we're going to touch on this later, particularly how we can become comfortable with uncertainty. But that's another component of this, right?
了解我们是如何做出生活决策的。所以他们做了什么呢，他们走到现实世界中，给人们一堆需要做出的决定，并伴随着这些决策提供可供选择的选项。但他们发现了一个非常令人惊讶的事情。当人们被给予太多选项时，他们几乎会陷入瘫痪，并且发现比选择较少时更难做出决定。这就是我们在心理学中所说的选择过载或选择悖论。我们经常认为拥有更多的选择或敞开的大门是极其解放的，它赋予了我们自主权，但它实际上产生了相反的影响。做出决定变得令人不知所措，令人恐惧
This illusion of control, the reason that we worry is because it gives us the sense that we know what we're doing. There is this other unique aspect of our 20s that I think also really contributes to this experience, to this natural worry about the future, choice, opportunities, open doors. Our 20s are really sold to us as this decade when the world is our oyster. It's at our fingertips. We can do absolutely anything that we want. It's when life really begins. This initially sounds amazing. You know, what's better than choice? What's better than endless freedom to determine our own life path as independent, curious people? But choice in this instance can actually be a double-edged sword. And I want to explain why. Back in the 1970s, a number of psychologists, they wanted to
因为我们有太多的潜在结果和风险，这些风险可能是由做出错误的选择导致的。拥有太多大致同样好的选项在精神上是消耗体力的，因为必须将每个选项与替代方案进行权衡以选择最好的一个，于是我们卡住了。我必须在这里提及我最喜欢的有史以来的一项研究。那是一项关于果酱的研究，其实不完全是关于果酱，但涉及到果酱。所以在2000年代初，斯坦福大学的这些心理学家决定在当地的一个农夫市场上设立一个摊位。在第一天，他们展示了24种不同类型的果酱，然后在第二天在同一个食品市场，他们只给人们6种果酱的选择，结果呢，
understand how we make life decisions. So what they did, they went out into the world and they gave people a bunch of decisions to make and with that options to choose from. But they found something really surprising. When people were given too many options, they became almost paralyzed and they found it much harder to make a decision than when they had fewer choices. And this is what we call in psychology choice overload or the paradox of choice. We often think that having more options or doors open to us is incredibly liberating and it gives us agency, but it actually has the opposite impact. Making a decision becomes overwhelming, becomes fearful
但当人们只有6种选项、6种果酱的选择时，他们购买一罐果酱的可能性要大得多。他们没有那么犹豫不决，因为他们的选项变少了。现在，这个实验，听起来虽然很奇怪，但可以应用到我们在二十岁时为未来担忧时所经历的瘫痪状态，以及为什么我们发现自己几乎无法做出决定。社会、我们的家庭、我们的社会环境，他们告诉我们可以成为任何东西。我们可以成为医生、律师、从事营销工作、全职父母或播客主。你知道吗，这选择太多了。
because we have so many potential outcomes and risks that may result from making the wrong choice. Having too many approximately equally good options is mentally draining because each option, must be weighted against alternatives to select the best one and we become stuck. I just, I have to mention one of my favorite studies ever done here. It was a study about jam, not really about jam, but involving jam. So in the early 2000s, these psychologists from Stanford University, they decided to set up a store at a local farmer's market. and on the first day they displayed 24 different types of jams and then on the next day at the same food market they gave people the choice of only six jams and well what would you know
我们只想拥有六种果酱。我们只想拥有六种选择。当我们开始质疑自己是否做出了正确的选择，是否为时过早地关闭了任何大门时，我们开始感到无比担忧。正是从那时起，我们一直在谈论的那种瘫痪、优柔寡断和恐惧开始占据主导地位。而在这个年纪发生的另一要素是，
but when people were only given six options six choices of jams they were much more likely to purchase a jar they were a lot less indecisive because they had less options now they This experiment, as strange as it sounds, it can be applied to the paralysis we experience when we're worrying about our future in our 20s and why we find ourselves almost unable to make a decision. Society, our family, our social environment, they tell us that we can be anything. We can be a doctor or a lawyer or in marketing or a stay-at-home parent or a podcaster. And you know what, that's too many options.
无论你是20岁还是29岁，我们都没有足够的生活经历去真正了解或开始把握我们到底想做什么，我们甚至喜欢什么，什么能让我们快乐。我们可能有一些概念，但事实是，我们还没有见识过足够多的世界，甚至不知道外面有什么。所以我们在面对关于未来的选择时的依据是有限的。我们真的不知道。我知道这可能会让人感到非常害怕，但有一件事总是能安慰我，那就是世界上许多精彩人物的所有那些故事，
We only want six jams. We only want six options. And when we begin questioning whether we're making the right choice, whether we're closing any doors to prematurely, that's when we start to feel incredibly worried. That's when that paralysis we were talking about, that indecision, that fear begins to take hold. And the other element of this that occurs at this age
他们在35岁、50岁、70岁时，改变职业，尝试全新事物，重返大学，重新开始。这对我来说太不可思议了，它是一个惊人的提醒，提醒你并没有被锁定在任何特定的未来中。你拥有自主权。你可以改变。没有什么能阻止你在十年后决定自己可能想要一些不同的东西，然后勇敢地去追求。我认为很容易落入社会为我们设下的这个陷阱，告诉我们我们需要
whether you're 20 or even 29 is that we haven't had enough life experiences to even know or begin to grapple with the idea of what we want to do, what we even like, what is going to make us happy. We might have some idea, but the truth is that we haven't seen enough of the world to even know what's out there. So our basis for this choice when it comes to our future, our evidence is limited. We really don't know. And I know this can feel so scary, but something that always reassures me is all those stories of the many wonderful people in the world
把一切都弄清楚。那是谎言。那根本不是真的。生活是如此奇妙，充满了变化和可能性，它是属于你去追求的。但在我们继续之前，我只想花一秒钟谈谈那个误解，因为这究竟是从哪里来的？我真的不知道，对于这么多人来说，这竟然是恐慌和不确定性的根源。那么，你必须知道自己在做什么这个神话是从哪里开始的？我有一些理论，当然也有其他人有他们自己的理论并通过研究来弄清楚这一点。
who, at 35, at 50, at 70, they change careers, they try something completely new, they go back to university, they start again. That is so incredible to me and an amazing reminder that you are not, locked into any future for yourself. You have agency. You can change. There is nothing stopping you from deciding, you know, 10 years from now that you might want something different and just going for it. I think it can be really easy to fall into this trap that society is set for us that tells us that we need
我想这不会让任何人感到惊讶，但这与社会比较有很大关系。我们非常自然地倾向于将我们的进展和决定与他人进行比较。将自己与他人进行比较，是一种社会本能，它使我们倾向于被群体视为正常的事物，我们利用这些信息来对我们应该在哪里以及我们要去哪里做出判断。但我们的大脑在选择现实的比较点方面并不是那么擅长。
to have it all figured out. That is a lie. That is just not true. Life is so weird. and full of change and possibility, and it's yours to go after. But before we move on, I do just want to talk about that misconception for one second, because where does that even come from? I really don't know, and it is such a source of panic and uncertainty for so many people. So where did this myth that you need to know what you're doing begin? And I have a few theories, and of course there have been other people who've had their own theories and conducted studies to figure it out.
我们的社会在向我们展示其他人 在我们这个年纪的生活真实写照方面也做得很不好。所以我们最终与之进行比较的人，往往是那些少数极其幸运的人，他们不知怎么地已经把一切都弄清楚了，或者在这个年纪已经取得了如此巨大的成就。就在上周，福布斯“30岁以下30岁俊杰”榜单出炉了，我在社交媒体上到处都能看到关于它的公告和图片，我的第一反应就是将自己与这些人进行比较，然后陷入焦虑并质问自己，你知道，我哪里做错了？为什么我没有达到这个阶段？我是在落后吗？这种思维模式是非常不理性的，但它本质上源于我将自己的个人发展与他人进行衡量的本能。我们的大脑喜欢选择无法企及的榜样来进行比较，这完全没有帮助，但这也是我们无法控制的。
I don't think this will surprise anyone, but it has a lot to do with social comparison. We are very naturally inclined to compare our progress and our decisions to those of others. Comparing ourselves to others, it's a social instinct that orientes us to what is perceived as normal by the group, and we use that information to create judgments about where we should be and where we're going. But our minds are not that great at choosing realistic points of comparison.
这就是为什么当我们经常对自己的进展感到如此担忧时，是因为我们在看着那0.00%已经把一切都弄清楚的人，并认为那是常态。但我现在要告诉你一个秘密。没有人知道自己在做什么。没有人知道。即使对于那一小部分确实知道的人，他们也绝对不知道自己五年或十年后会在做什么。在这个意义上，他们和我们一样。
And our society is also not great at showing us an accurate depiction of what life is really like for others at our age. So often the people we end up comparing ourselves to are those very few lucky ones who have some of managed to figure it out or who have already achieved so much at this age. This past week, actually, the Forbes 30 under 30 came out and I was seeing announcements and images about it all over my social media and my immediate reaction was to compare myself to these people and to spiral and question, you know, what am I doing wrong? Why am I not at this point? Am I falling behind? That pattern of thought was highly irrational, but it was inherently derived from my instinct to measure my own personal development against someone else's. Our brain likes to choose unattainable examples to compare against, which is entirely unhelpful, but also out of our control.
如果你对社会比较特别感兴趣，我曾做过一整集的节目来探讨它。如果你想了解更多，可以去听那一集，但我认为这是一种非常复杂的相互作用。当我们思考对未来的恐惧时，这一切其实都归结为这四个基本概念，对吧？是预期的焦虑，它为我们提供了这种控制的幻觉。是自我保护，以及想要感觉自己为可能发生的一切做好了准备。是选择悖论。是被太多的机会弄得几乎瘫痪，以至于我们甚至无法挑选。还有社会比较。是认为你需要走得更远。你需要做得比你已经在做的更多，因为你正在寻找
This is why when we often feel so worried about our progress, it's because we're looking at the 0.00 of people who do have it figured out and thinking that that is the norm. But I'm going to tell you a secret right now. No one knows what they're doing. No one knows. And even for that small minority who do, they certainly don't know what they'll be doing in five or ten years from now. They're just like us in that sense.
不切实际的成功榜样。但我不认为我们需要被这种恐惧所瘫痪。我认为我们可以从对未来的担忧中获得解放。这是我过去一年来巨大的个人旅程，学习如何活在当下并享受我现在的所在。相信我，这是一个艰难的过程。你知道，就在上周，我还对我现在所做的决定是否意味着我能在10年后获得幸福产生了强烈的不理性焦虑。所以你并不孤单。我接下来真正想要专注的是，我们如何能够应对我们的恐惧，如何应对我们的恐惧，如何应对。我们的担忧并向前迈进，我们如何才能从对未来的这种焦虑中解脱出来。
And I did an entire episode on social comparison if you are particularly interested in this. So listen to that if you want to. understand more, but I think it is this really complex interaction. When we think about our fears for the future, it all kind of boils down to these four essential concepts, right? It's anticipatory anxiety that provides us with this illusion of control. It's self-preservation and wanting to feel like we're prepared for whatever happens. It's the paradox of choice. It's being almost paralyzed by having so many opportunities that we can't even pick. And it's social comparison. It's thinking that you need to be further ahead. You need to be doing more than you're already doing because you're looking at
过度思考既具有破坏性，又极其消耗精神。它会让你觉得你被困在一个地方，我认为不对这种习惯采取行动也会影响我们的日常生活并加剧事情的发展。比如我们的焦虑水平或决定瘫痪。但我们来这里不是为了反刍不好的事情，而是为了展望我们可以采取哪些措施来对抗这种消极的认知模式。关于恐惧和担忧的事情是
examples of success that are unrealistic. But I don't think that we need to feel paralyzed by this fear. I think that we can find freedom from worrying about the future. And this has been a huge personal journey of mine this last year, learning how to live in the moment and enjoy where I am right now. Trust me, it's a difficult process. You know, even last week, I was having so much intense irrational anxiety about whether the decisions I was making right now were going to mean that I was happy in 10 years. So you're not alone in that. And what I really want to concentrate on next is how we can address our fears, how we can address our fears, how we can address. our worry and move forward how we can release ourselves from this anxiety about the future.
它通常被困在我们的脑海里，困在我们的思想中。所以重新训练我们的大脑以快速抛弃这些想法，是至关重要的。这并不意味着完全消除压力的感觉，而是改变我们对这种体验的感知或反应。当你发现自己开始陷入螺旋时，带着兴奋的心情来对待你的焦虑。兴奋和焦虑感觉非常相似。它们引发相同的赛跑般的思绪，胃里的同一种感觉，相同的身体反应。所以如果你坐在床上，真的很担心未来会怎样，担心你会身在何处，他们会有什么，你知道，你父母曾拥有过什么，
Overthinking is both destructive and also incredibly mentally draining. It can make you feel like you are stuck in one place and I think failure to act on this habit can also impact our day-to-day life and exacerbate things. like our anxiety levels or decision paralysis. But we're not here to ruminate on the bad, but look forward to the things that we can do to counter this negative cognitive pattern. The thing with fear and worry
担心你现在是否在正确的地方。把这种感觉当作兴奋来对待。告诉自己，我对这种感觉感到兴奋。我对这种感觉感到兴奋。我已经准备好被生活惊艳了。我已经准备好看看会发生什么。通过这种方式，你不再将躯体反应视为危险的或令人恐惧的事情，而是视为一种积极的体验，一种我们对所经历的事情抱有积极看法的体验，对吧？就像，每个人都宁愿感到兴奋，也不愿感到压力或焦虑，但它们会产生相同的身体反应。所以你对它的感知，你对那种感觉的想法，
is that it's often trapped and contained to our brain, to our thoughts. So retraining our brain to quickly dispose of these thoughts, is super crucial. This doesn't mean entirely eliminating the feeling of stress, but instead changing our perception or our reaction to this experience. When you begin to find yourself spiraling, approach your anxiety with excitement. Excitement and anxiety feel remarkably similar. They elicit the same racing thoughts, the same feeling in our stomach, the same physical reactions. So if you're sitting in bed really worried about what the future holds, worried about where you'll be, where they're going to have, you know, what your parents had,
实际上可以改变反应的性质以及它被你的身体和大脑体验的方式。有时这并不总是可能的。你知道，有一些关于未来的重大问题很难让人感到兴奋。比如，海平面上升会摧毁我们的生活方式吗？你知道，这可不是一个有趣的问题。但这并不需要阻止我们，
whether you're in the right place right now. Treat that feeling like excitement. Tell yourself, I am excited by this feeling. I am excited by this feeling. I am ready to be surprised by life. I am ready to see what happens. That way, you're no longer treating the somatic reaction as dangerous or something to be fearful of, but as a positive experience, one in which we have a positive perception of what we're going through, right? Like, everyone would much rather be excited than feel stressed or anxious, but they create the same physical reaction. so your perception of that, your thoughts towards that feeling,
或者它不需要阻止我们减少围绕这种可能性的焦虑。我曾经有一个治疗师给我提供过这个建议，我发现它非常有用，也许对你也是如此。安排时间去担忧。就像你安排时间去锻炼或处理生活杂务一样，每天给自己仅仅20分钟的窗口期来放纵自己进行一些轻度的过度思考。
can actually change the nature of the reaction and how it's experienced by your body, but also by your mind. Sometimes that's not always possible. You know, there are some big questions about the future that it's hard to feel excited by. Like, are rising sea level is going to destroy our way of life? You know, not a fun one. But that doesn't need to stop us,
我经常发现更有效的方法其实是在那段时间里写下我所担忧的事情，尽情地写日记。当这20分钟结束时，我把这一切留在纸上然后走开。这显然需要大量的自律，但如果你愿意尝试，它在将你的恐惧与你的日常生活和体验隔离开来方面可以非常有效。有时我们也只需要一点分心。正如我之前提到的，为未来担忧实际上会给我们的身体带来很大的压力。它会使我们的皮质醇水平飙升。它会导致失眠，加剧先前存在的心理健康状况。所以我们需要从大脑中跳出来，进入身体。
or it doesn't need to hold us back from reducing our anxiety around that possibility. I had a therapist once offer me this tip and I found it really useful and maybe you will as well. Schedule time to worry. The same way you schedule time to exercise or to do life admin, each day give yourself just a 20 minute window to indulge in some light overthinking.
我们可以通过几种方式做到这一点。但我最喜欢练习的方法是我和我的朋友称之为疯狂舞蹈。我知道这听名字真的很搞笑，而且挺简单的。对吧？但本质上，我放一首我绝对喜欢的歌，把它放得超级大声。然后我只花五分钟以最疯狂的方式移动和跳舞，让我的身体随心所欲地移动，感受节奏以及我的身体是如何反应的。它把我从那种身体焦虑和身体反应中带出来，进入一个更当下的空间。你会发现，当你扎根于当下，扎根于你的身体在做什么、你的四肢要去哪里、音乐的节拍时，思考未来和体验存在主义的恐惧以及
I often find it more effective to actually write out exactly what I'm worried about in that time to just journal my heart out. And when that 20 minutes is up, I leave it all on the page and I walk away. It obviously takes a lot of self-discipline, but if you're up for it, it can be incredibly effective in separating your fear from your everyday life and experiences. There's also times when we just need a distraction. Like I mentioned before, worrying about the future can actually put a lot of pressure on our bodies. It can spike our cortisol levels. It can create insomnia, heightened pre-existing mental health conditions. So we need to get out of our minds and into our bodies.
焦虑要困难得多，而且它是极其欣快 的，我从那种状态出来时总是带着一种平静感。它还有一个额外的好处，那就是能很好地释放体内的神经能量。我认为任何形式的锻炼实际上都非常适合这一点。诸如身体扫描、冥想或走到大自然中、与朋友交谈、去看电影等事情也同样如此，任何能让你的大脑休息一秒钟的事情。你知道，你真的值得拥有那份平静。与身体建立连接，消除了你的大脑用于你的不理性恐惧和
We can do this in a few ways. But my favorite way to practice this is what my friend and I call crazy dance. I know it sounds really funny and kind of simple. the name, right? But essentially, I put on a song that I absolutely love and I play it super loudly. And I just spend five minutes moving and dancing in the most insane way possible, moving my body however it wants to, feeling the rhythm and how my body is responding. And it brings me out of that physical anxiety and that physical reaction into a more present space. You'll find that it is a lot harder to contemplate the future and to experience existential dread and
不理性焦虑的能量。我想简要讨论的最后一个策略更加抽象一点，我想说也更难以应用，但绝对仍然值得注意。我们必须学会适应不确定性，适应我们对未知的恐惧。这种哲学有很大一部分根源于佛教，即我们无法改变发生在我们身上的事情，所以我们只能顺其自然，让生活的体验几乎冲刷过我们。因此，通过采纳这种几乎是斯多葛学派的哲学，这种斯多葛学派的意识形态，我们协助我们大脑消除了过度思考或担忧将要发生的事情的本能需求，因为
anxiety when you are grounded in the moment when you are grounded in what your body is doing where your limbs are going the beat of the music and it is incredibly euphoric i always come out of it with such a sense of calm it also has the added benefit of just being a great reliever of nervous energy in the body i think exercise of any form is actually great for this. But so are things like body scans and meditation or getting out into nature, talking to a friend, going to a movie, anything to just give your brain a break for a second. You know, you really deserve that piece. And connecting with your body removes kind of the energy that your brain is devoting to your irrational fears and
我们知道无论那是什么，我们都会找到一条出路。我们几乎对它变得被动，就像如果这要发生。它就会发生。我无法改变任何事情。要达到这一点，重要的是要反思你生命中那些发生意料之外事情的时刻，那些超出你控制的事情，而你活了下来。你挺过来了。把这种认可带到今天，把它加入到你的问题解决工具包中，作为一个提醒，提醒你能够并且你以前也曾坚持过。你生命中有那么多可怕的事情是你没有想到的，是你永远无法预测的。但你现在正在听这个。你还在。你挺过来了。我认为同样重要的是，通过尝试新事物来体验变化中的喜悦和兴奋，
to your irrational anxiety. The final strategy that I want to briefly discuss is a bit more abstract, I would say, and I think a bit more difficult to apply, but definitely still worth noting. We have to learn to become comfortable with uncertainty, with our fear of the unknown. This philosophy has a lot of roots in Buddhism, and the belief that we come change what happens to us so we just have to ride the wave and let life's experience almost wash over us therefore by adopting this almost stoic philosophy this stoic ideology we assist our brain in eliminating the instinctual need to overthink or worry about what's going to come because
将自己推向舒适区之外进入新的情境，这样你就能适应不适的感觉，也能适应随之而来的回报。只要看着你真正从某种恐惧中解放出来。我并不是说这是瞬时发生的，但它会有所帮助。我们可以慢慢地更好地处理对未来的担忧。我想我们今天也讨论了一点关于预期焦虑的内容，我顺便强调了一些它与广泛性焦虑症和抑郁症之间的联系。有时，寻求帮助确实是值得的，去找一个专业人士，一个有执业资格的人，来协助你完成从恐惧到平静的转变。我为此做了一整集的节目，题目好像是你在二十岁时获取治疗的指南，但我真的相信，如果这是你个人正在经历的问题，获得一些专业帮助将改变你的人生。你知道，
we know that whatever it is we will find a way through we almost just become passive to it like if this is going to happen. It's going to happen. I can't change anything. To get to this point, it's important to reflect on the times in your life when something unexpected happened, something beyond your control, and you survived. You made it through. Bring that acknowledgement into the present day, add it to your problem solving toolkit as a reminder that you can and you have endured before. there has been so many things in your life that was scary that you did not expect, that you never could have predicted. But you're listening to this right now. You're still here. You made it through. I think it's also important to experience the joy and the excitement in change by trying new things,
在一个播客中，我所能做的事情和所能说的话是有限的，它对你的帮助也是有限的。所以我真的认为这是一个绝佳的机会，能够真正与这些恐惧的基础建立连接，与你对未知恐惧的根源建立连接，并超越它。借此机会，我只想花一点时候提醒你，
pushing yourself beyond your comfort zone into new situations so that you can become comfortable with the feeling of discomfort, but also the reward that comes from that. And just watch as you truly do become liberated from some of that fear. I'm not saying it will be instantaneous, but it will help. And we can slowly get better at dealing with that worry about the future. I think we've also spoken a bit today about anticipatory anxiety, and I kind of highlighted some of the links between that and generalized anxiety disorder and depression. Sometimes it is worth just getting help, going to a professional person, someone who's
无论你在担忧什么，那都是没问题的。没有答案也没关系。未来真的很诡异。我们知道它正在到来，但我们永远无法完全确定它包含什么。所以体验恐惧是完全自然的。当我说这句话时，请相信我，你并不孤单。
practicing, to kind of assist you through the transition from fear to peace. And I did a whole episode on this called, I think it's like your guide to therapy in your 20s, but I really do believe that if this is a problem that you're personally going through, receiving some professional help will be life-changing. You know, there's a problem. only so much I can do and only so much I can say on one podcast that is going to help you. So I do really think it's an amazing opportunity to really connect with the basis of these fears, to connect with the root of your fear of the unknown and kind of move past it. And on that, I do just want to take a moment to remind you,
有时，最好的认可之一就是知道无论生活向你抛出什么，无论那种经历的性质如何，你在这条路上永远不会孤单。这对我来说感觉如此欣慰，知道这是会被分担的。这将是一种共同的体验。会有其他人同时也在经历它。我想，尽管我们是如此具有适应力的生物，但我真的向你保证，一切都会好起来的。如果你让生活给你带来惊喜，也许你会发现自己处于一个比你想象的还要更好的地方。
whatever you're worried about, that is okay. it's okay to not have the answers. The future is super weird. We know it's coming, but we can never fully be sure of what it contains. So it's entirely natural to be experiencing fear. And trust me when I say that, you are not alone.
生活在这方面真的很有趣。我想有时你期待所有这些事情。你花那么多时间为它们担忧，突然之间你的生活处于一个完全不同于你想象的地方，而你只会想：“哇，我太高兴我没有提前去预测这个了，因为我感到如此惊讶，而且结果比我想象的还要好。”我希望如果你能听到这里，你学到了一些东西
Sometimes that's just one of the best acknowledgments to just know that whatever life kind of throws out of you, whatever the nature of that experience is, you're never going to be alone in this. that. That feels so comforting to me to know that it will be shared. It will be a mutual experience. There will be other people going through it at the same time. And I think as much as we are such adaptable creatures, I really do promise that it's going to work out. And if you let life surprise you, maybe you'll find yourself in an even better place than you could have imagined.
有时，最好的慰藉莫过于知道，无论生活向你抛出什么，无论这种经历的本质如何，你永远不会孤单。这让我感到非常欣慰，知道这一切是会被分担的。这将是一种共同的体验。同时还会有其他人也在经历这一切。而且我认为，尽管我们是如此适应力强的生物，但我真的向导它会好起来的。如果你让生活给你带来惊喜，也许你会发现自己身处一个比你想象中更好的地方。
Life is really funny that way. I think sometimes you expect all these things. you spend so much time worrying about them and suddenly your life is in a completely different spot than you ever could have imagined it and you're just like, wow, I'm so glad I didn't anticipate this because I'm so surprised and it's worked out even better than I could have imagined. I hope that if you've made it this far, you've learned something
生活就是这样有趣。我想有时你对所有这些事情有所期待，你花了那么多时间去担心它们，突然间你的生活处在一个完全不同的境地，这是你做梦也想不到的，而你只会觉得，哇，我太高兴我没有提前预料到这一切了，因为我感到如此惊喜，而且它的结果比我想象的还要好。我希望如果你能坚持到这一步，你已经学到了一些东西
or at least feel a little bit less alone in your fear of the future. I know that it's really normal to spiral, it's really normal to overthink. and as a fellow 20-year-old I have been going through this so much recently and I'm just kind of trying to get comfortable with not knowing and seeing what comes my way. So I really hope that you enjoyed this little slice of the internet today, this episode.
或者至少让你们在对未来的恐惧中不那么孤单。我知道胡思乱想很正常，过度思考也很正常。作为同龄的二十岁年轻人，我最近也经历了很多这样的时刻，我只是在努力习惯这种未知，看看生活会带给我什么。所以，我真的很希望你们能喜欢今天这期节目，这网络世界中的一小片天地。
It was an absolute pleasure to be able to explore this topic a bit more and there was so much psychology and science that I didn't really get to cover. So if you want a part two, If you want a more scientific part two, more research-based, I would totally be willing to do it because I think that this is one of those topics in psychology within the discipline that there has been so much research into and it's just so incredibly valuable. So please let me know. And as always, if you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to pass it on. Share it with someone who you think might like it as well or leave a five-star review on Apple Podcast. Spotify, wherever you are listening right now, it really does help the show to grow.
能够深入探讨这个话题是一种绝对的享受，还有很多心理学和科学内容我没能完全涵盖。所以，如果你想要第二期，如果你想要一期更科学、更基于研究的第二期，我完全愿意录制，因为我认为这是心理学学科中研究非常多、并且价值极高的一个话题。所以请告诉我。而且一如既往，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随意转发。把它分享给你认为也会喜欢它的人，或者在Apple Podcasts、Spotify或你现在收听的任何地方留下五星好评，这确实对节目的成长很有帮助。
I read all of your reviews and they make me so happy and so emotional. So thank you to all of you who have left such kind words. If you want to be involved with the community, follow us at That Psychology podcast on Instagram. It is a really great way to participate in polls, give episode suggestions, see what's coming up soon like match like guest episodes all of those things so if you feel cool to do so please feel free to give us a follow and as always thank you so much for listening i hope you learned something i hope you enjoyed this episode and i hope you have a lovely week we will see you again next week for another episode hey what's good y'all you're listening to learn the hard way
我阅读了你们所有的评论，它们让我非常高兴和感动。所以感谢所有留下如此暖心话语的人。如果你想参与这个社群，请在Instagram上关注@That Psychology podcast。这是参与投票、提供节目建议、了解即将推出内容（比如嘉宾访谈节目等）的绝佳途径，所以如果你愿意的话，请随意关注我们。一如既往，非常感谢你们的收听，希望你们学到了一些东西，希望你们喜欢这期节目，并祝你们度过美好的一周。我们下周同一时间再见。嘿，大家好，你们正在收听的是《Learn the Hard Way》
with your favorite therapist and host care games this space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor? It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人Care Games主持。这个空间聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方并不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人穿着铠甲？它向世界传达出你不是好惹的信号。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的生父。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini. My mind was blown.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你曾两次篡改这份特定的测试报告，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格，一位女同性恋。迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子彻底炸裂了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love trapped podcast on the Eyeheart. Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面对了后果。请在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听播客《Love Trapped》。2%。这就是旁边有自动扶梯时仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO.
我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了心理韧性、健身的科学，以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的法则。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。那是数字TWO。
on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。请收听《The Girlfriends》。相信我，宝贝。
on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast, guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一个iHeart播客，纯人类制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。